auch jungen leuten kann das corona virus
gefährlich werden in frankreich ist
jetzt ein 16-jähriges mädchen an kuwait
19 gestorben
dennoch glauben viele immer noch dass
nur ältere und menschen mit
vorerkrankungen gefährdet sind doch das
ist ein fataler trugschluss und jetzt
gibt es erste indizien die anhaltspunkte
für schwere und leichte verläufe liefern
liegt um science fiction die gibt es
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's reichel
kommen wer dieser tage den new yorker
gouverneur andrew cuomo bei cnn gesehen
hat dem könnte es respekt vor dieser
krankheit einflüssen seine botschaft
auch wenn man einen schwächeren verlauf
der erkrankung hat ist cupid 19
eine ziemlich angst einflößende
infektion denn die symptome können auch
wenn sie ein nicht das leben kosten sehr
heftig sein so erlebt er es gerade er
hat sich angesteckt und kann jetzt nicht
mehr an vorderster front gegen das virus
kämpfen sondern befindet sich in
häuslicher quarantäne
die krankheit ist wirklich ziemlich
unkalkulierbar und es ist auf den ersten
blick nur schwer zu verstehen manche
menschen die mit dem virus saß kopf 2
infiziert sind merken sogar kaum oder
gar nichts davon vielleicht fühlt man
sich etwas schlapper als sonst oder hat
halsschmerzen tausende andere menschen
dagegen sind weltweit bereits an der
erkrankung mit 19 gestorben
die schäden an der lunge sind bei ihnen
so groß dass sie keine luft mehr
bekommen einen kreislaufschock erleiden
oder aber das herz versagt es handelt
sich also um krankheitsverläufe die eine
extrem große spannweite aufweisen und
genau das ist charakteristisch für das
neuartige virus es macht den eindruck
als ob hier das alter ein entscheidendes
kriterium sei junge menschen und vor
allem kinder stecken die erkrankung
meistens besser weg als ältere dazu die
wissenschaftlerin ulrike protzer aus
münchen wir haben noch nicht verstanden
weshalb der verlauf bei älteren
infizierten schwerer ist kinder aber in
den meisten fällen kaum symptome zeigen
in der wissenschafts community gibt es
bislang nur vermutungen warum der
krankheitsverlauf bei sehr jungen
menschen im großteil der fälle eher mild
ist möglicherweise ist dies dadurch
begründet dass der körper von
kleinkindern sehr gut auf den
erstkontakt mit neuen teilen
ausgerichtet ist denn das ist ja der
hauptjob des immunsystems in den ersten
lebensjahren das immunsystem von älteren
menschen dagegen
vor allem auftrumpfen wenn es auf
erfahrungen zurückgreifen kann denn so
können bereits vorhandene immunzellen
schnell reaktiviert und vermehrt werden
um gegen ähnliche während loszulegen
doch genau hier liegt das problem denn
das corona virus ist dem menschlichen
immunsystem gänzlich unbekannt je älter
die menschen sind umso weniger gut kann
die krankheits abwehr also mit diesem
erreger umgehen es dauert viel zu lange
ehe die wichtigen immunzellen neu
gebildet werden das virus breitet sich
also im menschlichen körper aus und das
ungehindert wir sind vor allem
diejenigen mit einem geschwächten
immunsystem der pferde und eben auch
ältere menschen sind den viren oft
schutzlos ausgeliefert doch sicher ist
niemand denn wie das robert koch
institut schreibt kommen schwere
verläufe dieser erkrankungen eben auch
bei jungen menschen vor ebenso auch bei
menschen ohne vorerkrankungen daher auch
die warnung des gesundheits sekretärs
der weltgesundheitsorganisation pedrosa
shalom an die junge generation ihr seid
nicht unverwundbar sein appell an alle
jungen soziale kontakte meiden und auf
abstand gehen
stay at home und socialiste singh also
dem kann auch der münchner arzt clemens
länder zustimmen er hat die ersten
corona fälle in deutschland behandelt
nicht nur ältere sondern auch junge
menschen landen in seiner klinik auf der
intensivstation der mediziner sagt in
einem zeit -interview wir müssen auch
junge menschen künstlich beatmen die
sind in ihren zwanzigern und dreißigern
mussten nach wenigen stunden in der
notaufnahme intubiert werden
daher auch die warnung die jungen
menschen sind nicht unverwundbar
manche wiegen sich da in einer
sicherheit die es nicht gibt das zeigt
jetzt auch an dramatischer fall aus
frankreich dort ist ein 16 jähriges
mädchen am kuhweg 19 gestorben schwester
und mutter warnen jetzt zitat niemand
ist gegen dieses mutierte virus
unbesiegbar laut dem französischen
gesundheitsministeriums war es wohl eine
besonders aggressive form des corona
virus diese sei allerdings extrem selten
bei jungen leuten so die angaben der
behörde auch in anderen ländern wurden
bereits todesfälle durch cupid 19 bei
jüngeren menschen ohne vorerkrankungen
gemeldet unter anderem aus italien
spanien und den usa
wie und warum es hier zu solchen
schweren krankheitsverläufen kam ist
noch nicht abschließend geklärt
möglicherweise liegt es aber daran dass
das virus direkt
die lunge eingeatmet wurde so bekam der
körper nicht die möglichkeit sich auf
die erreger vorzubereiten normalerweise
beginnt die kurve 19 erkrankung im
rachen und die viren vermehren sich dort
einige tage bevor sie in die lunge
gelangen in diesem fall bekommt das
immunsystem also zumindest einige zeit
um antikörper zu bilden welche
medikamente gegen korona helfen sehr
fundiertes video von spectrum video hier
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar den top kanal das wissenschafts
verlag spektrum in unserem wissenschafts
netzwerkes 1054 also pflicht aber hier
draufklicken bis dann bleibt dran